kelly aurait trouvé un mec ça fait
partie des infos médias dans un instant
une ceinture que le catch investigations
alors forcément on va vous montrer de
résumé de cette sombre affaire
regardez elle sait qu'elle y vit novelli
la première djette au monde à n'avoir
jamais touché un disque de sa vie
lorsqu'elle arrive en tp mpl fait
chavirer le coeur du beau maxime gainey
malheureusement comme on dit dans le
milieu
maxime gainey est un bar il n'arrivera
jamais à la pécho alors
notre homme va tenter d'entrer dans la
vie de la jeune djette il s'agit d'un
certain anthony un garçon que l'on a pu
voir entre autres dans l'émission
culturelle
les anges tout commence le 17 décembre
2017 quand anthony entre en contact avec
la djette via un célèbre réseau social
tout se passe très bien et comme disent
les jeunes il se chine
mais soudain kelly coupe les ponts mais
ne donne plus aucun signe de vie
une personne de l'équipe de touche pas à
mon poste lui aurait conseillé de lâcher
la faire pire encore de ne pas se mettre
en couple avec lui qui a poussé qui lie
à mettre fin cette histoire d'amour
naissante
comment maxime guinea va-t-il réagir en
découvrant qu'il a de la concurrence et
surtout comment qualité d'eau bedie
fait-elle ou bon mix et sans jamais
passer aucun disque toutes ces questions
auxquelles l'inspecteur baba va tenter
de répondre il faut dire la vérité parce
qu'il a dit ce garçon anthony a dit que
vous étiez en chine avec lui ouais et
que quelqu'un de l'équipe j'aurais dit
lâche la faire on a d'ailleurs la vidéo
regardez ah bon ce qui se passe et qui
vivait de vesly tu lui a déclaré ton
amour et ta travail je vais parler moi
aujourd'hui je parle plus à dire la
vérité à cannes pourquoi ça dérange
certaines personnes faisait que lui en
parler on verra
on a parlé du coup je vous dit peut-être
elle t'a dit quoique ça la dérange et
qu'on associe à toi elle acquit mes
photos moi je l'aï cassée photos sur
instagram et il ya des gens qu il
remarquer à son travail sur a et puis et
puis elle m'a dit voilà on embête avec
ça et tout je dis ben c'est quoi
permettre à des besoins vous parlez plus
à cause de ça il a dit à son travail
oui ok alors je suis pas seul et ouais
c'est bon je peux y aller serrer les
tiens on me dit il ya un taux qui veut
répondre à kevin fait notes audio tu
veux on s'en fout pas encore la réponse
j'ai dit je vous dirais c'est parti j'ai
des infos en direct alors cette histoire
c'était il y a environ 3 4 mois tu sur
le dossier ben haim a ajouté sur
snapshot
oui on s'est parlé pendant une ou deux
semaines deux trois semaines
de quoi justement apparemment ce n'est
pas littérature alors justement on
parlait de choses de la vie c'est
quelqu'un de très correct maintenant
donc on est deux personnes très correct
d'accord c'était pas du chaînage de fou
même presque pas on va dire démocrate
était c'était sûr cela me donne envie
c'est bon c'est bon ah oui merci comptez
pas sur un champ voilà ça la question
est très correct c'est vraiment très
sympa très correct
moi un moment donné je cyril soyons oui
donc allé j'ai pas trouvé ce que c'était
fou on enduit mois cette mesure
c'était très délire entre nous voilà
j'ai pas eu d'atomes crochus avec lui
content que je les aime follow de
instagram voit de bonnes raisons mais je
les vends vieux quand j'écoute tout ça
il avait une photo oui j'ai une foi
d'instagram ouais mais attendez attendez
pour des raisons alors alors qui vous a
dit moi j'aimerais savoir quelle est la
personne qui vous nourrit je vous
explique dietmar pour deux raisons la
première c'est qu'on n'avait pas
d'atomes crochus donc je voulais lan
solo parce que des thermos qu'on a juste
une réaction de matthieu delormeau
oui et deuxièmement oui parce que je ne
voulais pas qu'on voit que je suivais
cette personne parce que après les gens
regardent beaucoup qui en suit et alors
c'est vous qui avez pris la décision
c'est ok j'ai pris la décision tout seul
et je lui ai dit tout seul parce que je
ne voulais pas qu'on regarde je n'ai
jamais parlé de mon travail j'ai jamais
parler de l'apport voilà mais c'est
alors vous étiez en chine a dit et puis
finalement vous êtes blogueur finale
little china douane avant c'était pas
votre délire finalement c'était pas mon
des liens donc voilà pour pas le vexer
aussi voilà il y aurait à dire oui je
t'ai pas qu'ils croient en cette affaire
tout ça c'est la vérité mais il est très
gentil et très respectueux et ben merci
dont elle à el al attiyah
conseiller dans la bande de jeunes
fallait que je reste
qui vous a conseillé de l'homme folle
aux personnes mais raison c'est qu'ils
n'avaient pas de chine a des qui se
passait rien et vous mentez ça se voit
que vous montez écoutez sa réponse à la
déco casque allemand
oui totalement
non on va dire les mâles alors elle
émane bien mais alors que l'on y avait
un problème
moi je ressens pas du tout cette
histoire et puis à la fois ça me gêne
parce que j'ai fait une émission de télé
hier et on en a parlé avec quelqu'un que
tu vois c'est vraiment le sujet dont
tout le monde parle on vous a parlé de
lui avec une autre mais voilà voilà
il est sur tous les dossiers et oui il
est pas dans la finance parce qu'à gâtés
sur un an à 12,7 mm bon bah voilà n'y a
pas de calcul à quelque chose on va très
bien merci en tout cas vous avez réglé
toute la vérité
merci 6 3 franchement vous avez une tête
est honnête
bah oui ça aura été un jour michel jours
douloureux faut voir